bonjour baciro chez merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france il ya davantage de morts et
d'admissions à l'hôpital selon les
derniers chiffres alors que jérôme
salomon le directeur de la santé a
affirmé que le couvre-feu fonctionnait
très bien un commentaire bonjour
écoutez je les chiffres que vous n'êtes
données démontrent effectivement ce
qu'ils aiment détruit ce qui vient
d'être dit la stratégie elle a
fonctionné pendant trois quatre cinq
semaines hélas aujourd'hui entendre en
plus qu' on pourrait être avec les mêmes
mesures de sortie de crise dans cinq à
six semaines
comme l'a dit le chef de l'état lierse
et c'est mentir en fait encore une fois
et donc même si ça a permis
je pense que c'était opportun pour
pouvoir ralentir nico aujourd'hui
d'autres mesures deviennent absolument
nécessaire on voit quelle est la
situation particulièrement les vingt
départements qui ont été citées ce
week-end on a l'impression que
l'exécutif cherche à à tout faire pour
gagner du temps finalement évité un
grand compliment c'est votre sentiment
oui oui mais on comprend parfaitement
cette stratégie de des jt enr
confinement le problème c'est quand on
va arriver au bout du bout du doubs de
ce creux de ce qui pourra être fait avec
le couvre-feu moi ce que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est que le critère
principal c'est la saturation du système
hospitalier et qu' il réussit une note
stratégique pour être en place un c'est
celle de mettre fin aux plans justement
de suppressions de lits dans l'hôpital
aujourd'hui est d'essayer dès maintenant
d'anticiper et de créer des nids
provisoire mettre en place en deux
structures qui pourraient permettre
d'accueillir justement les des patients
plus nombreux on sait qu'ils seront plus
dans le dos dans les semaines à venir
ça n'est pas fait donc leur confinement
on en parle
quelque chose d'inéluctable message
effectivement c'est plutôt vers ça qu'on
voit et notamment parce que il n'y a pas
de volonté ouvre de l'exécutif de
remettre en cause la façon dont
justement le système sanitaire est
capable dentiste d'encaisser ouverte le
choc de cette crise d'aujourd'hui
l'exécutif qui est temps de
territorialiser les mesures il a
consulté hier la présidente d'île de
france valérie pécresse également anne
hidalgo la maire de paris qui a qualifié
un éventuel confinement le week end à
paris d' inhumain écoutez la maire de
paris et on en parle après quand je ne
propose de multiplier par quatre la
vaccination
c'est à la fois pour les plus de 75 ans
mais aussi de permettre par exemple à
nos policiers et à tous les agents qui
régule sur l'espace public nos présences
de pouvoir être également protégé 1re
confinement en ile de france ce week end
la piste est sur la table à l'effet
rieuse mans envisagée par le
gouvernement
une telle mesure à paris sachant que les
personnes vivent dans de petits
logements parfois ça vous paraît tenable
écoutez moi je partage ce que j'en dis
enfin ce qu'elle dit à la mairie de
paris à savoir que ces mesures de
confinement sont effectivement intenable
le dire en plus on désormais densité
sont les plus fortes
en revanche ce qu'il faut aussi éviter
c'est la fluctuation des prises de
position politiques dans la période
moi je ne comprends plus justement
quelles sont les positions aujourd'hui
de la mairie parler quand on voit des
déclarations qui ont pu avoir lieu la
semaine dernière de la part du premier
adjoint
il faut essayer justement d'éviter un
delà dans la réaction
la crise sanitaire peut être un élément
de de l'analyse politique et peut être
même un objet de réflexion aux
politiques mais si on se pose d'autres
le soin des questions de fond si on se
posait façon dont le système sanitaire
comme je le disais doit pouvoir
encaisser cette crise si on se pose tous
des questions sur la sortie de crise
sans s'opposer questions sur
l'accompagnement social
mais jouer avec ces histoires de
confinement je trouve ça vraiment comme
on n'a pas respectueux des gens qui
subissent ce confinement et cette menace
de confinement qui va vraiment falloir
voilà arrêté qui des décisions qui
soient prises et qui seront prises par
les autorités sanitaires en plus le le
conseil scientifique
moi je ne le comprends pas pourquoi
cette instance et a disparu aujourd'hui
du circuit de prise de décision
visiblement donc donc voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut rétablir et puis par ailleurs
par contre là où je suis entièrement
d'accord avec ce que dit anne hidalgo
c'est clair il ya un échec patent est
grave de la part des gouvernements
c'était aujourd'hui la question
vaccinale votre précédent invité en
parlais tout à l'heure mais évidemment
que la seule sortie de crise possible
c'est la démultiplication du vaccin et
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir du coude
et de nouvelles mesures qui seront mises
en oeuvre sur la question nationale et
il sait pas simplement ce qui est
annoncé aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée
progressive de stock nouveau avec
l'extension de la stratégie car d'autres
tranches de la population
est ce qu'il faut c'est se poser de
vraies questions sur la façon dont en
france on va pouvoir produire un vaccin
quels qu'ils soient sont arrachant des
licences soit en demandant
justement de reprendre un certain nombre
de recherches mais en tout cas ce n'est
plus possible d'être dans cette attente
parce que la sortie de crise encore une
femme ne se fera qu'avec d'une stratégie
vaccinale est claire et efficace vous
parler de la stratégie vaccinale on le
voit les médecins de ville sont de plus
en plus réticents à vacciner parce que
les contraintes sont trop importantes
il y à un quart des des vaccins
astrazeneca qui ont été inoculés mais il
reste les trois quarts dans les
pharmacies aujourd'hui donc comme un
commentaire sur cette gestion des
vaccins décentralisée au maximum c'est
justement là la possibilité de recevoir
et d'administrer un vaccin moi ça me
semble être une bonne idée
aujourd'hui il ya de vrais hommes qui se
posent visiblement c'est d'abord un
problème de fiabilité d'effets
secondaires sur la lgv astrazeneca moi
je suis pas médecin et donc je le dis
simplement ce qu'il dit là dessus et
donc il faudrait peut être réfléchir à
la façon dont on utilise ce vaccin qu'il
serait peut-être un peu moins efficaces
et qu'on aurait peut-être plus d'effets
secondaires
à ce titre d'ailleurs j'ai entendu des
propositions intéressantes et qui
visaient à l aile réservée aux 6
également pour pour les jeunes pour les
étudiants de façon à ce qu'ils puissent
juste c'est là la difficulté et la
détresse notamment des étudiants
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'une façon de
revenir de façon plus en plus certaine
les universités se serait aussi de leur
adresser une partie de ce virus de façon
à ce qu'ils puissent reprendre
non pas une activité normale une et une
certaine activité après le problème est
toujours le même
problème c'est le nombre de doses et
donc ça a effectivement c'est au
gouvernement de nous dire à quel horizon
si cet horizon de cinq à six semaines
qui est évoquée de sortie de crise
c'est un horizon dans lequel on sait
qu'on aura une capacité de deux vaccins
suffisante pour moi pour reprendre
justement une fin d'activité normale et
a coûté tant mieux mais j'ai au moins ma
crainte c'est que dans cinq à six
semaines non seulement la stratégie du
couvre-feu et les choux et que donc on
soit contre un confinement mais qu'en
plus on n'est toujours pas d'avancée
significative sur la question vaccinale
est là pour le coup on sera vraiment une
vraie difficulté
merci beaucoup aux vestiaires et chez
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france